ضجه كبيره اثارها انتشار فيديو على مواقع
التواصل اجتماعي تظهر من خلاله الفنانه
السوريه اصاله وهي تحمل سيجاره الكترونيه
في كواليس برنامج سعودي ايدول الفيديو اثر
عاصفه من الانتقادات الغاضبه ضد الفنانه
ما دفعها للاعتذار عبرت تويتر بعد تدخل
الفنانه احلام للدفاع عنها اصاله شاركت
تغريده احلام وشكرتها على ردها واعتذر عن
تصرفها وقالت الف شكر على كلامك الطيب
شعورك الغاليه واليوم كنت راح ارد واعتذر
على تصرف فيه طبعا مكان المفروض اشرف بيك
قدام الناس بس كان وقت التصوير طويل واخذت
من صديقه موجوده وشركت منه شويه للاسف
صوروني بكرر اعتذاري رح اكون احرص على
صورتي اللي كلنا سوا شاب
ملكه
[موسيقى]
حياه الفنانين ما مليئه بالدراما والجمهور
جزء لا يتجزا منها فهو يرغب باستمرار في
معرفه اخبار النجوم المفضلين ويعلق عليها
وينتقدها في بعض الاحيان مثلا الفنانه منه
شلبي اثارت اثمتها الاخيره الكثير من
الانتقادات بعد الحكم عليها على خلفيه
اتهامها لاحراز مخدر الحشيش بقصد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في مصر بصوره
نشره الفنان احمد الفيشاوي مع ابنه بعد ان
اعترف بناس به اخيرا الامر الذي فتح الباب
لتعليقات متابعيه وتحدثنا البعض عن قصه
قديمه تؤكد ان لديه ابن من سيده المانيه
رفعت دعوه قضائيه قبل عامين تطالب خلالها
باثبات نسمي
وانتقادات كثيره اثارتها الفنانه شيرين
باخباري زواجها وتطلاقها وحلاقه شعرها
وتعتها المخدرات وخلافاتها مع عائلتها
ووعدت الجمهور بانها ستكون اكثر حرسان
وتكتما في حياتها الشخصيه لحظات صعبه ايضا
عاشتها ذره زروق عقبه زواجها من رجل اعمال
هاني سعد بعدت الدوله الكثير من الشائعات
انه لم يطلق زوجته الاولى مما يعني ان
النجم التونسيه ستكون الزوجه الثانيه وهو
ما يجربه القانون التونسي ما جعلها عرضه
الكثير من الانتقادات حتى نفذت ذلك
سالنا الناس ما رايك في نشر خصوصيات
الفنانين عبر مواقع التواصل
[موسيقى]
شخص اللي يصور خصوصيات المشاهير او
خصوصيات ممثلين
فهمم عباره عن انه يريد ان يحطم المشهور
يعني المشهور ناجح مبدع همم في مجله
فيحاول ان يحطمه فيحاول يصيد اخطائه يقوم
يتصور يتطفل انه ممكن هذا المشهور واثق
بالشخص هذا وكان مع بعض هذا نجح وهذا لا
للاسف اصبحت ظاهره سيئه جدا الحقيقه
الفنان الانسان
بطبعه والله انا اشوفها صراحه النفس واول
زمان يعني كانت حنا عندنا الخصوصيه اساس
اساس كل شيء الحرفيه والله اني اشوف
الخصوصيه بصراحه لها حدود مو اي خصوصيه
تطرح العالم يعني السوشيال ميديا لازم
يكون في لها حدود صراحه
فصالات مشاكل
هذا شيء جديد علينا وانا صراحه
لما اجي قولا وفعلا ومرئيا ما يجوز ابدا
ابدا
[موسيقى]
الفني ومن المنامه طارق البحار رئيس قسم
الثقافه والمنقعات في صحيفه البلاد
البحرينيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك استاذ احمد
الى اي مدى يحق للجمهور نشر خصوصيات الفن
على متابعي صباح العربيه بس يعني انا ما
بعتبر خصوصيات بدايه
هي مانعه يعني اصاله مو قاعده ببيت
والشباب دخلوا لعندها واقتحم خصوصيه
بالنهايه انت بكواليس برنامج مهم بكواليس
بعكس حفلين بعد فنانين معك جمهور يعني من
الطبيعي معك مصورين حتى من الطبيعي يعني
ما اسم خصوصيه ابدا رني انت قاعده بمكان
يعني بمكان محاطه بالكاميرات من جميع
الجوانبه
خصوصيه ابدا على اختراق طيب يعني هاي
النقطه خلينا نقولها لطارق من المنام يعني
طارق وجهه نظر احمد قد يراها لبعض محققه
جدا فيما يتعلق انه الخصوصيه في الموضوع
هي اصلا في مكان عام وموجود في برنامج
مسابقات بس ليش اعتذرت لما لما بتعتذر
اعتراف ضمن منها بارتكبها خطا
صباح الخير عليكم جميعا اييه والله انا
اشوف الموضوع هذا موضوع شويه يعني يكون
غالبا يكون مدروس يعني في مشاهير كثار
موجودين حوالين
يحبوني يسوون بلبله عشان الاسم ينتشر يعني
يعني اليوم في برنامج قوي جدا من العربيه
في صباح العربيه قاعدين نناقش موضوع اصاله
خلينا نشوف احنا من امس على تويتر وعلى
موقع العربيه طبعا موقع همم كبير انا
اعتمد على
نشر الاخبار
والمستقيم طبعا كم كم اسم اليوم كم واحد
بحث عن اصاله من بحث هذا الشيء فاليوم
احنا فينا نعرف حتى في مشاهير يعني حتى
صورها يعني نقول يعني انا انا يعني انا
عموما ضد يعني همم
ما عرضت يعني ما بينهم بس خلينا نقول لحد
كده سواها مثلا خلينا نقول احنا بيننا
يمكن اللي صورها عليها يعني هي اتفاق معها
همم صور واذا صاح
صار الترند اليوم راح يحقق الهدف في تارجت
الفنان داونز ابريل وصل له من ناحيه
التراندي الاسم او الترند العمل مثلا او
ترن انه تحديد اتفرج على البرنامج مثلا
وهذه كلها اشياء مطبوخه مثلا نقول لها بس
انا اشوف شخصيا ان الانسان ان احنا يعني
هي اصاله ما تعد همم
مثال يحتذى به مثل الا في في الفن في
الغنامه
طارق اليوم الى اي ماده نشهد الشعره ما
بين ان يكون الفنان او المشهور قدوه ومثال
للجمهوره وبين الركوب موجه التراند والبحث
عن الشهره مثلا
هلا بريء يا صلاح
لما بتعمل هيك شيء يعني صح صح بكواليس دي
كواليس البرنامج همم ولكن هي بالنهايه
في النهايه مثل ما قلت ما انا قاعده في
البيت
لكن الناس بتتابع اصاله لا تسمع اغانيها
اصاله ليست ناطقه بس منظمه الصحه العالميه
اصاله ليست طبيبه ليست مسؤوله في القطاع
الصحي والطبي لكي تلوموها على ما فعلته
يعني لو كانت تدرس مثلا هي اصاله
التدخين بنفهم انه هذه فضيحه وهذا لون لكن
عملت شيء اي انسان ممكن يعمله
في ملايين المراهقين بيتابعوها بالوقت
اللي قعدت الدواء اللي عم تفرض ضرائب على
التدخين عم بتكافح التدخين اغلب دول
العالم زادت اسعار المنتجات التدخين
والمنتجات بشكل كبير جدا بس هلا تتابع او
اي فنان او اي مشهور يتابع من قبل
الملايين المراهقين اللي بيشوفوه بشكل او
باخر خطبه يعني في نفس اليوم
المراه
السيد طارق همم كيف ترد على ذلك المفروض
اصاله كبيره وتكون قدوه لكل الشباب
بيحبوها
طيب هي ايام زمان انا قلت لكم
في شكلها تراند في غناءها كمغنيه يعني مثل
المذيعه المذيعه هي ترن بشكل جميل
بالقائها بطريقتها اما اما في الشاشه
شخصيه انا شخصيا ما اشوف انه مهم جدا يعني
احنا من سنين كنا نتابع همم فقط
المذيعه ترند في مضمونها قبل شكلها جميل
حتى نقول توم كروز مثلا
حب لفريق او عند هذه اوكي يعزز يمكن اشياء
بسيطه
شاشه شخصيه هي هي اصاله غلطه غلطه كبيره
يوم اعتذرت يعني والاعتذار هذه نرجع للمحل
المحور الاول كلمته اليوم احنا عندنا وايد
وايد وايد في اشياء همم تحدث لها ترند
لازم ترند ما حد مو محتاجه ترند الا نحن
نقول فن اليوم اللي رحنا في مصر احسن مغني
عمرو دياب لازم يسوي ترند هو لازم يسوي
ترند يركب الترنج مجنون مصريين فهو لازم
شو اسمه لازم همم
الوحيد اللي ما يدخن في البحرين كامل
في التدخين هذا
ما سويت شيء عظيم يعني والفيق موجود في كل
مكان عند الاجانب او البحرينيين او في
الخليج اساسا احنا عندنا في الخليج انا
عندي عند بيتنا من محل
صاير يعني شيء في الخليج وعادي طبيعي صار
عادي هو يعني
حتى احلام طلعت تريد همم في التويتر
يعني كل اللي يبين يعني واضح انه مستعد
جدا عشان يصل الى الفرنج ويصل الى هنا
طالع البرنامج عشان اشوف البرنامج سواء
البرامج زين مو زين هذا
الموضوع
اليوم كم واحد يعني عرب ايدول اليوم اكيد
بالعكس
طبيعي لكن المغني ذكي طلع اغنيه مثلا نقول
فاشله ينقذ روحه باغنيه ناجحه احنا طالع
عقب فتره تطلع اغنيه وكل بينسون هذه كل ما
يدري عنه شو صار البيت واحد يدري ولا يكون
معنا عقب كم يوم
كان معنا من القاهره احمد درع الكاتب
مناقد الفني ومن الملامه طارق البحاره
رئيس قسم الثقافه منوعات في صحيفه البلاد
بحرينيه شكرا لكم